stéphane ticket le secrétaire général
adjoint du think tank à droite libre
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france d'abord ou comment vous
vous percevez ce comité conduit par assa
traoré la saur d'adama traoré écoutez
nous sommes tous engagés pour lutter
contre le racisme
rappelons d'ailleurs que le racisme est
un délit et ce combat contre le racisme
ne sais pas le combat de linselles
affaire de tous peu importe de
longevialle peu importe quelle couleur
au soir à partir donc à quel type de
racisme c'est le combat de tous
maintenant je dénonce
lorsque des violences policières je fais
confiance à la justice à son travail
en revanche je ne suis pas d'accord avec
eux lorsqu'ils disent tu l'as français
par pinera fiscaux la société française
putschistes et raciste je considère qu'à
quelques personnes qui sont assistées
frères doivent être condamnées par la
loi et je les comprends sage tout pour
le faire mais je suis pas d'accord je ne
peux te dire que la france est un pays
raciste à société cette marche
aujourd'hui que s'est déroulée sans
écailles tel regard vous portez
justement sur le message qui a tenu à
livrer ce comité
bah on est ravi d'avoir une marche
indiqué c'est vrai que les dernières
images qu'on avait entre les la violence
avec la police était vraiment assez
déplorable on parle souvent des biopuces
rb n'ont pas passé si vous faites à la
police quand même parce que la police
aussi subi beaucoup de violence et ça il
faut le dénoncer moi je dénonce les
violences tête par la police pour
qu'elle ou telle chose c'est à dire que
ce soit pour une cause insiste encore
plus gênant soucier des violences sont
faites par certains à des policiers on a
décollé sait qu'il doit aussi de façon
régulière et ça aussi il faut doubler
donc je fais confiance à la justice pour
que
la ligne à 100 fait état fin traoré pour
que les familles de traoré puisse au
moins avoir la justice et je considère
aussi qu'il faut dénoncer des violences
qui son côté la police alors quatre ans
après la mort d'adama traoré l'enquète
allait relancer c'est une victoire pour
un fait militants aujourd'hui écouter
ces lampes été relancée samedi ce plan
que justin fonctionne à ceux qui pensent
que je suis ne fonctionne pas au caire à
suivre donc à justice sanctionne et à
cette enquête qui va partir il faut
laisser maintenant la justice travaille
de façon sereine afin qu'on puisse avoir
le résultat qu'on attend tous est que
justice soit rendue
si jamais il ya une culpabilité du au
racisme que ceux qui sont des coupables
on sent reconnu par la loi s'applique
comme il le mérite
et si jamais y'a pas de culpabilité
qu'on arrête de dire que la france est
un pays raciste que la société est un
des six était raciste et kaya racing est
à moi je ne pense pas qu'à quelques
personnes qui sont racistes on a entendu
quelques fois des démos de certains dans
la police et cela doit être coupable
parce que la police reconnaît l'autorité
dont police pour moi c'est 100%
autorités ce sont des gens qui
s'affichait au quotidien pour nous
protéger pour nous secourir qui nous
permettent de lutter aussi notamment
contre terrorisme et je pense qu'il faut
rendre hommage à tous ces hommes et à
ces femmes qui s'engagent aussi vidé
image déplorable cette semaine avec des
paupières aussi maintenant qu'ils sont
pressés dans les choix aux données de
l'autorité à ces gens là ceux qui
s'engagent pour nous protéger la police
et pompiers leur rendre hommage
dénoncer lorsque certains font un abus
de pouvoir pour telle ou telle cause et
encore plus lorsqu'il est dans des lits
comme le racisme n'est pas la sphère de
l'ain mais qui est l affaire de tous et
aussi de faut laisser la justice
travailler pour qu'on puisse avoir les
résultats
donc le fait la justice et que l'anc
être par manque la justice travaille
maintenant il faut laisser la justice en
paix pour avoir des résultats qu'au jour
de tous une dernière question c'est une
marche à laquelle s'est associée une ong
à écolo ça signifie quoi pour le
collectif pourquoi s'associer justement
avec un collectif pour le climat mais
j'aimerais j'aimerais sur le
permettaient de rebondir déjà j'ai
entendu que omar sy et dans d'autres
personnalités étaient présents à cette
marche là c'est une très bonne chose que
ça
mobilisent pour lutter contre le racisme
j'avais aussi voulu qu'ils se mobilisent
notamment pour ce qui s'est passé pour
le conducteur de bus qui est décédée
entre à toulouse qui faisait son travail
qui a été assassiné je vais aussi
mobilisés pour les pompiers qui sont
cassés il n'y a pas des causes qui sont
supérieurs aux autres forces mobilisées
pour toutes les côtes laissant le dit
pas assez
faisons blessé aussi pour les policiers
qui seront tués voilà ensuite qui est
des gens qui sont à rassembler ensemble
pour lutter contre le racisme c'est une
très bonne chose vous savez moi je suis
engagé je suis aussi contre le racisme
je suis contrôlé les violences
policières le racisme et donc on est
tous ensemble dans ce combat là voilà
maintenant il faut pas lui dire que la
police est là six cartes hépatites la
police c'est certainement la police il
complète la cité raciste car c'est
certain dans la société et et ça il faut
le dire aussi et enfin comme je vous
disais précédemment il faut laisser la
justice pouvoir travailler faire son
travail attend que justice soit faite et
qu'on puisse avoir moi la vérité de
cette histoire
merci à vous stéphane ticket je rappelle
que vous êtes le secrétaire général
adjoint du think tank à droite libre